Hugh's descended into one of the most
bizarre episodes of his life in December
1957 he told his personal aides that he
wanted to screen some movies at a nearby
studio called nossek's on Sunset
Boulevard Hugh stayed in the darkened
screening room
for more than four months never leaving
he used a telephone to conduct business
and ate a diet of chocolate bars and
milk but most of the time he just sat in
his own chair often naked watching
movies reel after reel day after day
Hughes issued strict orders to his aides
writing instructions on yellow legal
tablets do not look at him do not speak
to him only respond when spoken to
around hues were dozens of boxes of
Kleenex which he continuously stacked
and rearranged there's a famous memo he
wrote it was called the Kleenex
directive and it was a lengthy memo on
how to use Kleenex to protect yourself
from germs and you're supposed to use
eight to ten thicknesses of Kleenex in
order to open a doorknob
for instance as his stay at Nozick
stretched in two months
Hughes relied more and more on his
painkillers his personal hygiene
deteriorated rapidly but at the same
time he became more and more obsessed
with avoiding germs all manifestations
of obsessive compulsive disorder after
four months Hughes finally emerged from
the screening room in the spring of 1958
by then his clothes were soiled and
ragged he hadn't bathed or shaved for
months he was a mess the once
charismatic public figure had become a
pathetic recluse it has been surmised
that what happened at Nozick's was
Hughes was having a massive nervous
breakdown but he didn't want to tell
anybody so he kind of in a way
created his own asylum after leaving the
screening room
Hughes checked in to the Beverly Hills
Hotel where he lived in a bungalow for
the next few years he also rented many
other rooms for his aids wife in various
girlfriends one year I figured he spent
eleven million dollars at that hotel
imagine at the hotel Hughes relapsed
into his screening room habits sitting
naked in the dark covered only by a
strategically placed pink hotel napkin
but even as his behavior grew stranger
Hughes somehow kept control of his
amazing Empire